Driving my daughter to school,
and she said to me out of the blue, mama.
So, yes, baby.
She said, I'm the ugliest girl I know.
And I said,
huh?
And she was like, yeah,
I look like a boy with long hair.
And my brain went to,
oh, my god,
you're six. Why?
Where is this coming from?
Who said this?
But I said, when people make fun of me,
it's. That's what they use.
They say that I look like a boy, or I'm too masculine, or I'm too.
I have too many opinions.
I. My body is too strong.
And I said to her,
I said, do you see me growing my hair so? No, mama.
I said, do you see me changing my body?
No, mama.
Do you see me changing the way I present myself to the world?
Do you see me selling out arenas all over the world?
Yes, mama.
Okay,
so, baby girl,
we don't change.
We take the gravel in the shell, and we make a pearl.
And we help other people to change
so that they can see more kinds of beauty.